اهلا بكم اذن المؤتمر الوطني الليبي تكليف
عبد الله اثني بتشكيل حكومه جديده بعد
مطالبته بتوسيع صلاحياتها نتوقف مع هذا
الخبر لنناقشه في محورين ما دلالات هذه
الخطوه في المشهد السياسي الليبي
وما التحديات التي تواجه العمليه السياسيه
في المرحله القادمه
ما ان بدا ان ليبيا تتجه الى طي صفحه
الموانئ المغلقه منذ اشهر حتى بدات امام
تحد اخر يتمثل في مطالبه الحكومه برئاسه
عبد الله اثنين للمؤتمر الوطني بتوسيع
صلاحياتها لقياده المرحله الانتقاليه
من ازمه الى اخرى تمر ليبيا وتخرج اخر
ازماتها طلب حكومه عبد الله بمنحها مزيد
من الصلاحيات
فكان الرد تكليف المؤتمر الوطني العام
للرجل بتشكيل حكومه جديده وتلك لا يعلم
بعد هل ستستمر في اداره البلاد الى حين
اجراء الانتخابات ام لا فذلك رهن بالمؤتمر
العام استمرار ربما لما يقول ليبيون انه
ازدواجيه السلطه في بلادهم بين الحكومات
والبرلمان فهو يعين ويحاسب لكنه ليمنح ما
يكفي من السلطه والصلاحيه للحكومات ما
يجعلها عاجزه عن اجتراح حلول لمشكله
البلاد وعرضه للسخط الشعبي في الان نفسه
البرلمان او المؤتمر الوطني يعاني بدوره
من تجاذبات داخليه بين التيارين الاسلامي
والليبرالي تجعله مترددا براي كثيرين في
حسم الملفات الكبرى التي يديرها امر دفع
محتجين على اداؤه الى اغلاق طريق المطار
في العاصمه طرابلس
ويتهم هؤلاء البرلمان بالعجز والفشل وزاد
المحتجون على ذلك بالدعوه الى استقاله
رئيسه
ازمه الصلاحيات واجهت رئيس الوزراء السابق
علي زيدان في اخر عهده قامت مجموعات مسلحه
بتحميل ناقله بالنفط تصديرها هدد بنسف
الناقله في عرض البحر ولا حقها بزوارق
مسلحه من دون ان تستطيع حكومته منعها من
الوصول الى المياه الدوليه
وكانت النتيجه قيام المؤتمر العام بعزل
الرجل الذي فر لاحقا خارج البلاد بالتزامن
مرت موانئ البلاد الاخرى وخاصه في شرق
ليبيا
بسيطره محتجين ومجموعات مسلحه
الحكومه ولا المؤتمر انفاذ القانون ما
الجاها الى التفاوض اما بالغاز فلا يجد
اهلها سوى الاضراب الشامل احتجاجا على
الفوضى الامنيه و للمطالبه باستقاله
المؤتمر العام نفسه ويقول هؤلاء وسواهم من
منتقدي المؤتمر العام والحكومه الليبيه ان
غياب مؤسسات الدوله وصفه جاهزه لتمزيق
البلاد وربما تقود البعض الحنين الى
القذافي نفسه بعد اكثر من ثلاث سنوات من
الثوره عليه
ولمناقشه هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من
طرابلس كل من محمد سعد مع عضو المؤتمر
الوطني العام الليبي
والدكتور عبد الحميد النعمي استاذ العلوم
السياسيه في جامعه طرابلس
نرحب بضيفنا من طرابلس ابدا معك استاذ
محمد سعد معذب اه نريد ان نفهم في البدايه
ما الذي يسعى الى قرار مفاجئ مثل هذا
هذه مساء الخير وتحيه لك المشاهدين الكرام
اه هو لم يكن قرار مفاجئه طبعا حكومه
الاستاذ عبد الله الثاني
كلفت في المره الاولى على اساس الى حكومه
تسيير اعمال
وحددت لها المده باسبوعين ثم انتهت
الاسبوعين ولم يتمكن من المؤتمر من
التوافق على رئيس حكومه جديده مما اضطره
الى تمديد الاسبوعين الى اسبوعين اخرين
انتهت هذا اليوم الاسبوعين
وبالتالي لابد ان المؤتمر يحسم امره اما
ان يكلف السيد عبد الله الثاني في
الحكومه وهو تشكيل حكومه جديده او يختار
رئيسا جديدا
للوزراء اه طبعا الخيار الثاني متعذر لان
الكثير من الاعضاء اه ليسوا متواجدين
لاسباب مختلفه يعني مثلا فيه هناك حوالي
ثلاثين عضو اه كانوا
اه قد اعلنوا انهم لن يحضروا جلسات
المؤتمر حتى يتم البث في موضوع السيد نوري
بوسهمين رئيس المؤتمر
وكذلك هناك بعض ال
سبعه وسبعين عضوا من مجموع مائه عضو
اه نعم تقريبا هكذا يعني لا هو اكثر من
سبعين كانت
المحاضر اللي هو ثلاثه وتسعين عضو
قلت في البدايه يعني هذا ال القرار لم يكن
مفاجئا افهم منك انه اه تم يعني تقديم
انذار مسبق مذكرا مسبقه الى اه المؤتمر
بهذا القرار مثلا
هو طبعا اه كنا نعرف كاعضاء الجلسه اليوم
هي الجلسه التي يتم فيها حسم الامر
بالنسبه للحكومه لانها كما ذكرت لك اليوم
هو النهايه الاسبوعين اللي حددت حكومه
تسيير الاعمال وبالتالي اه ارسلت الى
رئاسه المؤتمر رساله لكل اعضاء المؤتمر اه
يوم امس على اساس تنبئ بان الجلسه اليوم
مهمه وضروره الحضور لانه سيتم في حسم
موضوع الحكومه ولكن للاسف كان هناك غياب
واضحا ولا بد ان نتخذ قرار في هذا في هذا
الموضوع
دكتور دكتور يعني انه يتم الا يطرح هذا
خلافا يعني قانونيا داخل المؤتمر الوطني
ان يتخذ قرار بوجود يعني اه اقليه لا
تعتبر اغلبيه حتى وان كان اكثر من تسعه
وسبعين عضوا كما اه يقول الاستاذ معدل اه
النظام الداخلي المؤتمر يقول ان من حقه او
سحب الثقه من الحكومه يتطلب مائه وعشرين
صوتا
هل هناك اشكاليه قانونيه في الموضوع
هذا القرار
الجدل ان من ناحيه المؤتمر الوطنيه تشترط
العشرين كما تفضلت حضرتك ومن ناحيه ثانيه
يتغاضى الاخوه اعضاء المائه على التكليف
والسيد عبد الله اثنين باغلبيه اثنين
واربعين
يعني احنا لا نفهم في القانون ولا في
السياسه اه مثل هذه النسبه من العراق مثلا
يعني
نسبه اعضاء المؤتمر
انا بالنسبه لنا المطلقه بالنسبه الخاصه
المطلوبه في
الحكومه اه اذن هذه الاغلبيه يعني من
ناحيه اذا كان فيه لتكريس عبد الله او من
ناحيه هي غير كانت من الاغتيال رئيس حكومه
جديد اذن هناك ازدواجيه في المعايير يعني
هناك تناقض في في الاسلوب المتبع من اعضاء
المؤتمر هذا طبعا دليل اضافي انتخب اعضاء
المؤتمر في هذه المرحله
ونتيجه بالتوتر
التوتر الرئيس هذا الشارع سنتحدث عن
التوتر والغليان في الشارع الليبي استاذ
محمد سعد معذب يعني عبد الله اثنيه عندما
يعين يعني رئيس حكومه نفهم من ذلك انه
يعني اه هو رئيس وزراء بمثابه رئيس وزراء
منحت له الثقه كرئيس وزراء بكامل
الصلاحيات
اه هو طبعا اه ال اليوم يعني اختير كرئيس
حكومه وطلب منه ان يقدم
التشكيله الوزاريه في ظرف اسبوع وطبعا كل
وزير سيخضع الى التصويت عليه وعرض اه
نبدا عنه مختصره في المؤتمر
ونتوقع ذلك ان يتم في اقل من اسبوع ان شاء
الله
وطبعا بالنسبه ل لا هو لم تكن هناك
لضغوطات ولا شيء من هذا القبيل ولكن نحن
وجدنا انفسنا يعني طبعا لابد ان يتم حل
يعني
السؤال
للسيد عبد الله اثنين هي لتشكيل حكومه
تسيير الاعمال
بصلاحيات كامله لفتره اربعه اشهر الى حين
حلول موعد الانتخابات التشريعيه ونهايه
ولايه البرلمان الحالي
نعم هو ح يستمر حتى بعد البرلمان الحالي
طبعا بالنسبه للبرلمان بالنسبه للمؤتمر
ينتهي بانعقاد اول جلسه لمجلس النواب
واللي هي نتوقعها خلال اربع وعشرون ان شاء
الله اه لكن هي الحكومه تستمر الى حين ان
مجلس النواب الجديد اه يقوم بتشكيل حكومه
جديده
دكتور عبد الحميد النعمي ما هي اليوم اذا
اولويات هذه الحكومه
من هذه الحكومه في المسابقه يعني هذا
الحكومه ثلاثه لديها رؤيه تتخبط بان يمينا
وشمالا شفنا الم المده الماضيه انهم عقد
اجتماعات واصدر الحرب على الارهاب اه في
قرار يعني لا نعلم بداه ولا ما انتهاء هل
هو مطلب من طرف خارجي هل هو مطلع هل هو
ضروره ملحه في المنطقه الجنوبيه هل هو
اشاره لدول الجوار الاوروبي الاشاره لبعض
القوى السياسيه كنا نعرف ان مثلا السيد
عبد الله رئيسا بالعلاقات الدوليه مثل ما
كان
وبالتالي نقدر نعتبر ان مثل هذا القرار
ومخلفات سيد زيدان
بالنسبه لهذه الحكومه
عندما طرح اسم على زيدان سابقا رئيس
الحكومه كان اسم عبد الله ايضا موجود ضمن
القائمه يعني ليس غريبا على الساحه
ولكن
هذا هو المنطقه
يعني
الوزير يعني
وزارته بمعنى الكلمه في معالجه هذه
القضايا واخرها دخول
وخروج دون ان تستجيب القوات البحريه ولا
القوات الجويه ل ل اوامر صدرت لها من
قياداتنا العسكريه اللي هو مشهور عليها
بالدرجه الاولى فاذن بدل من ان يحال الى
المحاكمه ويقال الى النائب العام يتم
ترقيته الى وظيفه اعلى
الاستاذ محمد
ان تمنح الثقه في المؤتمر الوطني لهذا
الرجل
وهذا الرجل فشل في اداره ازمه الموانئ وتم
كما كان يقول الان الاستاذ اه الدكتور عبد
الحميد النعيمي كيف لرجل فشل في حل ازمه
الموانئ ان يرقى الى مرتبه رئيس حكومه
بملفات مشتعله وسط شارع ابي يغلي ازمات
متراكمه ملف امني ثقيل جدا
لا هو هو بالنسبه للحكومه فيه طبعا اولا
ما نستطيع نحن نستعجل يعني يعني الرجل
اليوم كل رئاسه الحكومه اليوم فقط يعني
وما نستطيع ان نحكم عليه من يوم واحد يعني
من الصعب اما كنا كان وزير دفاع او حدثت
اه فشل في الاخفاقات هو الحقيقه دائما
يكرر دائما عندها مشكله في رئاسه الاركان
وهذه المشكله والمعضله ما زالت قائمه لحد
الان الثنائيه اللي موجوده في الدفاع بين
الاركان بالرئيس
وزير الدفاع ومع رئيس الوزراء السيد عليه
كانت معظم لو كانت مشكله وكانت اما
بالنسبه لمساله الموانئ فازمه الموانئ
النفطيه فكان مسؤوله عليها السيد علي
زيدان يعني وانا اه يعني ارى على الاحظ
يعني انه صارت حلحله لهذه المشكله اه صحيح
الحل غير مرضي للجميع صحيح انه فيه بعض ال
بعض الاشياء اللي هي في ال في الاتفاقيه
اللي وقعت ما هيش واضحه وضوح تام تحتاج
الى توضيح للراي العام الليبي ولكن وصلوا
يعني هم الان يعني وصلوا الى فتح من اين
من زاويتين او من الحقيقه في في
وبالتالي فيه خطوات جميع اه استطاع ان
يحقق ها في هذه ال اربعه اسابيع
وبعد الفاصل سنناقش اذا مستقبل العمليه
السياسيه الليبيه في ضوء التحديات التي
تواجهها البلاد مشاهدينا سوف
ام
مشاهدينا اهلا بكم من جديد الى هذه الحلقه
التي تناقش تكليف بتشكيل حكومه جديده في
ليبيا بعد توسيع صلاحياتها اه دكتور عبد
الحميد النعمي الان خلال الاشهر الاربعه
الاربعه المقبله قبل نهايه ولايه البرلمان
ال الحالي ماذا يمكن لهذه الحكومه ان تفعل
ما هو الشيء الملموس الذي يمكن ان تقدموا
في هذه الاشهر الاربعه
يتوقع منها الكثير
ما شفنا من طريق التفكير هذه الحكومه في
المرحله السابقه وطريق التقرير اثنين اه
يعني لا اتوقع منها كثير يعني فعلا امر
مؤسف جدا بان
الملف الرئيسي هو ملف الامن الامن طبعا هو
كان الاتصال بملف الامن ولم نرى منه شيئا
في المده السابقه طبعا هل هل ستتمكن الان
من بدايه اه او اعاده تنظيم قطاع الامن
والقوات المسلحه في هذه الفتره الوجيزه هل
سيتمكن من تسويه ملف العلاقه مع الدوار اه
مثلا جمع السلاح
اعاده المهجرين وملف
تسويه الاوضاع
المجرمين اللي خارج من السجون عددا من
الاحباط يعني فعلا هناك العديد من القضايا
اللي انا اشك في كفاءه مثل هذه الحكومه في
التعاطي معها يعني ما شاهدناه نتصرف مؤتمر
وطني يدل عليه عدم ادراك لابعاد الحقيقيه
للازمه بيعيشها الان مثلا عليه سواء في
الشرق او في الغرب يعني ال لاحظوا ان
الدوله بدات تفقد سيطرتها على الكثير من
المناطق يعني هي سيطرت عليه مثلا الموانئ
والمطارات
واه بعض المناطق الحدوديه وايضا ما شفنا
والان
شوف المؤتمر فعلا لا يواجه حقيقه مباشره
ويسعى
المغامرات والحسابات الداخليه بين الكتل
وما بين الاحزاب يعني ممكن نتوقع حتى في
المده السابقه المره القادمه ان الاخوه
فوضى الغازي يعمدون الى نوع من الاداره
الحاليه نوع من المجلس الانتقالي المحلي
لان مش وهم العزيز المؤتمر الوطني الان
يعني الان لا يمكن نستغرب اي اجراء يكون
بالاخوه في غزه وفي
معنى ذلك ان اي رئيس حكومه بدون صلاحيات
امنيه لن يستطيع ان يفعل شيئا وسؤالي
الاستاذ محمد سعد معدل يعني زيدان على
زيدان نفسه كان يشتكي من عدم توفر صلاحيات
كافيه اه بين يدي خصوصا في ال ال المجالات
الامنيه او ما يتعلق بالملف الامني الان
هل تعتقد ان عبد الله اثني
ستعطى له صلاحيات اكبر في اداره الملف
الامني
يعني القول بانه السيد علي الجدال لم تكن
عندهم صلاحيات كامله
غير
صحيح للقوات المسلحه من المؤتمر الوطني
قائد القوات المسلحه هو رئيس المؤتمر
الوطني ليبي القائد العام هو رئيس الاركان
اركان الجيش يعينه المؤتمر الوطني بحكم
الاعلان بالصور هذا الشيء معروف
لا لا هو هو هو رئيس الاركان طبعا يعين
بناء على اقتراح من الصين وزير الدفاع
لابد ان وزير الدفاع يقدم الترشيح من عنده
ثم يعرض على المؤتمر ثم يتم المصور
ولا ان علاقه القائد الامريكي
وزير الدفاع طبعا وزير الدفاع كغيره من
الوزراء يقوم رئيس الوزراء والسيد عبد
الله الثاني مطلوب منها ان يقدم التشكيله
الوزاريه
للمؤتمر خلال الاسبوع القادم ويتم التصويت
عليه وزير الوزير يعني الثقه تكون من
المؤتمر لكل وزير لكن بترشيح من السيد
رئيس الوزراء وكذلك وزير رئيس الاركان
بترشيح من السيد وزير الدفاع لابد ان يتم
في هذا السياق لكن انا بعد صلاحيات على
الزام بالعكس كانت عنده صلاحيات كامله
امنيه وكان يستطيع ان يتصرف وكانت عند
الاموال ولكن كان يستفيدوا من عدم اه اه
عند الامر كان يشتكي اه دوما من عدم توفر
صلاحيات امنيه بين يديه لكن اليوم المشكله
ليست فقط امنيه انتم على ابواب الانتخابات
في انتخابات مقبله في تجاذبات سياسيه
كبيره في البلد وقبليه ايضا في مطالب في
الشرق نظام فيدرالي وقبل قليل كان يتحدث
الدكتور عبد الحميد النعمي عن النزعه
الانفصاليه في بنغازي هناك مشكله الامازيغ
والمشاكل الثقافيه كل هذه المشاكل
المتراكمه
هل لرئيس الحكومه ان يحولها في هذه الاشهر
وهو طبعا ال مده قصيره جدا يعني اربع
شغلات التوقع انه يستطيع ان يصل الى حلول
جوهريه وحلول المشاكل الكبيره ولكن هو
طبعا الملف الامني هو الملف الاساسي هو
الهاجس الاساسي ونحنا ادراكا منا في
المؤتمر لهذا الامر حتى رصدنا ميزانيه
الطوارئ اه اثنين مليار ونصف في هذا الامر
يعني الجانب الامني بجانب الميزانيه
الاحتياطيه كذلك عنده الصلاحيات الكامله
اللي يتحرك هو وزرع طبعا نجاح وحكومه
الفني الحقيقه تحتمل احتمال اساسي على
مسالتين اساسيتين اولا اه لابد من اختيار
رئيس اركان جديد وثانيا لابد من اختيار
وزراء قادرين على ان يقفوا ويقوموا بهذه
الم لا يستطيع رئيس الوزراء وحده وان يقوم
بالمهمه وهذه هي مشكله حكومه هذه الزائ
الحقيقه ان بعض الوزراء كانوا قاصرين
كانوا فاشلين كانوا عاجزين بعض منهم يعني
اسمائهم
لا لا نحن الطريقه انه هو توا السيد السيد
الثاني يقدم لنا الوزراء ويقدم كل واحد
منهم يقدم نبذه مختصره ونصوت عليهم طبعا
اعتقادا منها بما يقدم الينا نحن لا نعرف
ما يحدث في المستقبل ولا نستطيع ان نختار
كل واحده على حده ولكن بناء على المعلومات
التي تقدم الشخص وبناء على ما نصل اليه من
من قرارات على اساس قرارات جماعيه
والتصويت و عدد معين من الاصوات ثم
يعطي المجال لكن كونا بعد ذلك يفشل هذا
الوزير او ينجح هذا الوزير هذا في علم
الغيب طبعا هذا لا لا نستطيع وايضا يجب
علينا ان نحنا كذلك يجب ان لا نظلم هؤلاء
الناس نحن الان فينا نعيش في في في وضع اه
يعني متفجر وضع خطير وضع يعني
الدكتور عبد الحميد هذا الوضع المتفجر
والخطير ماذا يتطلب اليوم من السياسيين من
الحكومه من رئيس الحكومه من المؤتمر
الوطني ومن الليبيين ان يفعلوا للخروج منه
هل المشكله في غياب حوار وطني فعال غياب
مصالحه وطنيه حقيقيه
اين يكمن الحل برايك المخرج من هذه الازمه
طبعا
متاخر حتى للحوار الوطني ان حتى الحوار
الوطني نشهده الان هو حوار مزيف هو حوار
ما بين من يعتقدون انه لديهم الاغلبيه في
الراي العام وهو
يعني الحوار ضمن العالم حوار دم المداخل
المطبخ للاسف الشديد يعني كل شيء مخيف منذ
اه بدايه هذه التجربه جديده ابتداءا
المجلس الانتخابي تكلف عناصر محسوبه على
النظام السابق بالمكتب التنفيذي
الجراح التنفيذي للسلطه واستمرت هذه السنه
الى حد الان وبالتالي الان يعني من الصعب
جدا ان ان تحدد عنصر واحد هو المسؤول يعني
الان الارتباك اصبح سيد الموقف واه اه اه
تقع بدات تنزع بين شركاء الامس
واصبح الساحه
الاجندات الخارجيه وكل يغني عليه الان
الان المؤتمرات انا اعتبر هو المسؤول
الرئيسي
هذا الاخفاق وهو اللي فعلا قدمنا تجربه
فاشله لمشروع 17 فضائح وهو الفعل الهياه
الى ارضيه الان في هذه المرحله لعوده
النظام السابق
كثيرون يعني طور يدور رئيس حكومه مفصل
تفصيلا لا ابوشاقور عجب الليبيين ولا على
زيدان عجب الليبيين ولا عبد الله
مثلا
اه
نشوفوا فيها في التلفزيونات
يعني مره في الشهر وبالتالي هذه طبعا
غريبه عن اوضاع البلد وبالتالي تم تكليفه
اداره
استاذ محمد
لم يبقى الوقت الكثير في دقيقه واحده كيف
ترى ان الحل
انا ارى الامور الحمد لله
يقدم
ترشيح رئيس مجلس الوزراء في ذلك ولم يحصل
على صوت واحد ولكن هو طبعا
من الخارج السيد الثانيه ومن الداخل داخل
الداخل وبدا يهاجم من الان لا يعجبه العجب
ولا
طبعا الناس المتفرج من بعيد واللي على
كرسي وثيره تستطيع ان تحل لو تنظر ولكن
الواقع الليبي نحن نعيش واقع متازم واقع
المجتمع كله يشترك في هذه المساله نحنا
فيه ولكن انا انظر الى امل وتفاؤل وبشرى
ونتمنى ان شاء الله نصل الى مرحله
الانتخابات لمجلس النواب والدستور ونصل
الى دوله المؤسسات والدستور قريبا باذن
الله رغم كيد الكايدين ورغم الاعداء
المحيطين بينها ورغم ال
المؤامرات التي تحاك بالد ليبيا في الداخل
والخارج ولكن نامل يب التفاؤل والبشري
والامل بان ناس نعبر اه في هذا ال في هذه
الطريق وسنصل الى دوله المستقبل
اشكرك محمد سعد عضو المؤتمر الوطني العام
الليبي كنت معنا من طرابلس شكرا جزيلا لك
ونشكر ايضا ضيفنا الدكتور عبد الحميد
النعمي استاذ العلوم السياسيه في جامعه
طرابلس ايضا قلت معنا من طرابلس شكرا لكما
وبهذا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما وراء
الخبر نلتقي باذن الله قراءه جديده ل ما
وراء خبر جديد لكم منا اطيب المنى والى
اللقاء
ام